Henry Cavill put everything into season
three he even had to watch to make sure
he didn't get too aggressive during
fight scenes because his adrenaline was
going that high and Freya Allen was so
excited about one moment she started
getting into spoilers you aren't gonna
believe what went on behind the scenes
of The Witcher season three
season three has one of the best fights
on the entire show it is a one-take
fight and what does that mean there are
no Cuts in here there's no cheat Cuts
either the camera operator needed to
move quickly and make sure he was in the
right place at all times or else he
could he could get by a flying prop or
Worse an actor we actually built in
originally some slow motion some fake
slow-mo moments where I would move in
slow motion Henry was going to perform
some of his stunts in slow motion and
then the editors would speed it up
afterwards to give the cameraman time to
catch his breath there was just one
problem but it didn't suit really this
fight they didn't want to change the
scene too much in editing so they
scrapped the slo-mo idea at that point
Henry almost had the opposite problem he
had to focus on not going too fast for
the camera to keep up we end up getting
a lot of adrenaline and quite aggressive
it took them 35 takes on the day of
filming to get everything right and that
isn't including the 90 takes they'd done
before that in training Henry must have
felt like he really was in medieval
times can you imagine what it would be
like to really be living in medieval
times it sure wouldn't be very
comfortable and Joey Beatty knows that
better than most there were a few times
on set where he felt like he really was
in medieval times we were constantly
muddy and cold we can definitely see how
that would be uncomfortable but Joey got
right into it he even asked the crew for
a little something to help set them dude
I did ask for some actual sort of
medieval Mead or wine to drink at some
point how cool would that have been but
unfortunately it didn't work out you
didn't give it to me I'm so gutters
better luck next season Joey but Freya
Allen is looking forward to something
specific this season what was Freya
Allen most excited about in season three
I just love the fights that's right the
fight scenes and not only that but there
was one actor in particular that she's
been excited to work with for years now
and then getting to do one with Henry I
mean I've been waiting for this month
you can really tell that he lived up to
her expectations because he is there's
no doubt fantastic at it even before
Freya was cast she used to watch Henry's
fight scenes in the hopes that she could
be like him someday better watch out
Henry before you know it Graham might
even take his place especially when I
take his lesson
Freya was way too eager to talk about
one scene in particular from season
three I get to Muse
um geralt's sword which is also merry
Clinton this moment was almost as
touching for our actors as it was for
geralt and Siri but Henry's last fight
scene got Joey really choked up he's
going out with a bang Henry Cavill
helped co-choreograph his final fight
scene for the show I've never seen him
work harder not only did he insist on
keeping up with the stunt team but he
was also suffering pretty bad at the
time too I believe he was he had a cold
at the time as well Joey was impressed
by how much Henry put into this final
fight scene with the fight team he was
never the one to sit down now Joey's a
big fan of Henry and says I think it's a
testament to Henry's hard work and
Henry's skill and talent but everyone is
going but no don't leave you were great
moments like Henry's final fight scene
are why Joey can see why fans are so
hesitant to let Henry go after the
season but he says that Liam's working
so hard
um training already and things like that
to come in and step into these enormous
shoes we just hope that Liam still takes
down monster is as interesting as this
season flash monster okay how freaky was
the creature geralt found in the
Subterranean case in episode 2. this
monster is literally made out of human
flesh which just has to be about the
grossest thing we've seen oh we it took
months for production designer Andrew
laws and his team to come up with the
final concept for the flash monster
because they had to coordinate so many
different teams to get it right law said
we had to deal with the dynamism of it
between Prosthetics creature concept
design VFX and trying to figure out how
to evolve this thing and make sense out
of it not only that but The Witcher team
also needed to work out stunts for the
flesh monster because lost said they
wanted to deal with their movement this
had to be one of the most collaborative
processes the show has ever had for
building a monster but at least they had
an easier time coming up with The
Witcher signs this season did you notice
how many Witcher signs there were in
season three we worked very hard at
making sure we involved more of the
signs in here if you're end of the books
then you may just have noticed geralt
pulling a few familiar moves against the
bad guys there's an odd in there this
switcher sign gives off a powerful blast
of psychic energy that staggers your
enemy and that's not all there's a
heliotrope this move is super useful for
being able to protect against an attack
the series changed the design of the
heliotrope Shield so that it could
provide geralt with more complete
protection rather than the
forward-facing shield that we used to
see in the game Henry wanted us to see
geralt use his full range of skills and
abilities this season because why would
he hold anything back especially when we
all want to see him go all out to
protect Siri The Witcher season 3 is
getting far more intense than you've
ever seen before whether it's geralt or
Siri holding the sword so which of these
behind the scenes stories were you the
most surprised to hear and what are your
thoughts on season three we'd love to
hear what you think so make sure to let
us know down in the comment section